this is a first viewing complete total
lie this is totally the first time we've
seen this
yeah so you okay there granny there was
an honest trailer for mmmm forever that
came out recently and they said yep this
is definitely the worst movie I've seen
40 times this is very much of that movie
when I saw this I didn't know what to
think of it like I wasn't sure I'm like
is this good it's bad I don't know but I
watched it like a million times
still just cuz I loved the first time
alone so much and even now like I would
see it in a while the whole way through
but like I still have a soft spot even
though I know it's not good home alone I
watch every year I'll watch the
commentary to home alone which is
actually really good
they make fun home below to all the
people there the people who made it make
fun of it no it's like gremlins too were
Joe Dante says welcome to the most
unnecessary of sequels I like Evil Dead
to where they make fathers oh yeah
following this sense of humor so grow
the fuck out here we go this is second
third fortieth viewing below - but I
haven't seen it in a while John Hughes
production the film that could arguably
kill what was left of his career and she
totally did yeah cuz they just wanted to
make these babies day out Kluber
the masterpiece oh I forgot about that
makes way too much sense even the music
is like here we go again here we go
again go again go again go again he is
the one thing that's better in this yes
buzz is how much better he evolved as a
character like he's not a better person
but he's a better liar the funny thing
is like anybody was brothers like we
recognize this insulation yeah in the
same shit we pull i've got spiders here
and then this is the tomo brother moment
okay you look out sniffer all i do a
side by side of the language between the
two films because in the first film
they're really harsh and really swearing
and NFL
real and genuine they here trout sniffer
and cheapskate it's like Oh skate like
this is news they Ninja Turtles tuned it
now this is the 90s now we have to
protect children but let's get this
straight we have to protect children by
removing the language literally creating
a saw like funhouse that's fine
Columbus is one of those people I don't
usually like his movies but I respect
the hell out of them like how hard they
try yes in like the atmosphere I love
the production design in this film yeah
he has good Atmos yeah but jeez you guys
get the worst called dirt wake-up calls
called arns
can he say that at all darn huh boarding
but put him in baggage oh I love this
radar screamer there's only two you know
hair airspace was always assuming this
intellectual post yeah Miami's awesome I
killed some freedom
now it's fish it's fish dip you look
positively charming and kind of cute
with all the birds down the hall to the
left
[Music]
this is where it is you did come through
on your promise it wasn't it was a weird
promise to make to begin with you
promised me I would find the lobby who
promises that you need to lie about it
just what you do know I'm here to make
you movie better my wallets in my bag
Kevin was looking at my bag at the
airport he was looking for batteries
I'm putting the plot together as we're
speaking but he doesn't have as well
because it isn't it Oh if I take up the
key and just replace it with I'd there
I've got my pod now let me just show you
how to use the three seashells and we
can get that was every kid's dream come
true I think most kids who wander around
the room it's like it's a hotel room but
it's like you open the fridge it's like
damn hook EES jelly beans yeah like
that's what do you two have in the ice
cream on the bed and everything I'm just
like yeah no I do this - what bellhop
does them that seems kind of Rob
Schneider yes this is the best part of
both movies the movie within the movie I
could smell you getting off the elevator
yeah well I can hear your obvious ADR we
can't have any sex we can't have any
swearing but at least you didn't say
naughty words I think this is when every
adult in the audience was like we're not
coming back are we this is the movie
we're gonna get hey I don't like the way
those dolphins are positioned
the days before Yelp Groff lives here
stay back from Paris
I'll drop in on them you get that
audience okay
uncle rob is awesome but he's also out
of town so he doesn't have time to deal
with this good shit that's why he's
awesome I know I just don't feel like
that connection like oh I really miss my
family no it's not earn so because they
did it in the first film I think they
feel that's what earn did but it's not
this film has to earn it again and we
had to do it all again and like they
played this scene kind of too early he
hasn't even encountered anything that
scary yeah have a lovely day lovely
Christmas we gotta whack
Jimmy the squid if they run into snakes
oh that's right remember snakes
something you never saw in the 90s yes
never saw this Andy he was the first to
ever do that Doug not I really did that
like the 90s now that I'm thinking about
anything that said no I'm not doing this
shit I'm not doing yes I'm not doing
that I'm not doing pratfalls like Batman
and you know Animaniacs is doubly anyone
that said no we're not doing that shit
that was the good stuff Tim Curry for
our movies that we have to watch it's
like a good luck charm any piece of shit
has made ultimately better right to
encourage you know was Tim Curry made it
okay to laugh at stupid shit yeah
because he still brought this dignity to
it like no it's okay you can laugh at
how stupid this is he brings dignity
credibility but also over the top could
be the accessibility he gives it his own
okay I would JIT like tonight or there
too it's just like Shane I got a gun in
my pocket there was kind of this the
other one it's like we're getting to do
all the things he did to ID so we're
gonna hit him on the hand with a bucket
or me it's like I'm gonna fuckin shoot
you in the head well I sweet it's uncle
Rob's place have you heard the good news
Jesus say
oh no I mean Columbus's other field
adventures in babysitting that movies
fuckin amis scary oh it's better at hey
kids look out for that cab driver it's
like he had lot enough self-esteem to
know he's not very good-looking the kid
is scared by him cuz he's a little shit
it's like I feel really bad for the cab
driver no kid I'm a gentle giant no I'm
sorry
there is nothing scary about her she is
not scary at all if she came out be like
hi how you doing that Burt Richard I was
afraid of getting my heart broken again
please explain this leap from being
dumped to living in the dump it's like
if the dude from the first movie was
like yeah my son never talks to me so
now I live in the bell tower and shoe
people like wait how did you get there
and then I rode across on the Titanic
and then I came here but riding on the
back of a t-rex in the heaven because
he's also like oh you're crazy it's not
a complex series of socio-economical
issues or the fact that I've got a
severe mental illness nup me heart
yellows like you know it's not about me
anymore or gain comeuppance today it's
for the kids I gotta fight for the kids
so I'm not gonna call the cops tell them
the show up to this place and rest their
asses I'm still gonna put all these
stupid low jokes together repeat the
score repeat the score doing it again
here we go again yeah so I'm just saying
this now uncle Rob's gonna come home and
be really pissed
madam there are hundreds of parasites
out there there is a bird lady who is
living out there feeding birds because a
heart was broken broken and I ask you
dangerous
emotional baggage is staggering she
carries around bird seed danger gets on
Sam know if anybody used to throw it on
to dim-witted burglars hello the armpit
doesn't the register Oh God
you can see his brain
it's so it's so people it wouldn't work
if there's a pong or clean on the banks
in every event that ever feels so hard
it's so not home alone
that's what's so strange about it it's
like gonna be for you home alone there's
no ingenious right it's just hitting a
guy with a brick you know what if that
was all the traps I would have a strange
respect for this right into a bed of
nails
all these fears of fatality what you're
the last thing I just did I clearly
shouldn't look down at the ground the
setting in this makes it even more saw
like a fish it was such a nice home and
this one it's like a horrible that's
true just enough where it's like okay
it's like this isn't good as a little
kid I would like watching this over and
over like night dude I do find these
stuff all laughs how the game things
better but there's a couple of things
there it's like okay they got a lab the
brick is the high-water mark and that's
where it's done yeah my favorite memes
man now they get strays and noses they
kill him
I heard of it amazing Merry Christmas I
love watching you burn
ah the city of New York has failed you
Kevin it wants you dead just two
skeletons left like critters like what
the balls awesome I see stuff and the
boys at the NYPD put yourself in your
kids shoes where would you go wait
I probably lying dead in a gutter
somewhere but Kevin probably would be
horrific Lee
torturing her I'd be dead together
somewhere but Kevin he'd be making other
people dead in the gutter I'm assuming
right at this very moment he's there
when nobody else would be there
there's impossible I can see all could I
just see my mother
Oliver Warren another thing as long as I
live I just want my mother your school
panting this I had to do like five
nickelodeon appearances and like 12
Choice Awards and that's what I'm to
memorize all these lines do I apologize
for this is kind of your fault I don't
know this is this is a weird one
Kevin hadn't screwed up in the first
place again why isn't there a buzz alone
his girlfriend oh it was actually named
wolf I would also go with home buzz who
are you and that's when Kevin realized
she is all science and here's my gift to
you it's just a pile of bird shit it's
gorgeous here we go the movie just like
rushes itself like I parents you're free
go just go yeah I think buzz is the only
thing that's better in this room he
improved with age like a fine wine yes
it's about how I remember it
it's not good but there's enough fags
sort of have a soft spot for it it's
like Ghostbusters - I know it's bad I
know it's a sequel there's a couple
things where I'm like okay that was kind
of worth it that was a little fun just
like a Ghostbuster Stewart Peterman
Nichols yeah this one has Tim yeah there
it is guys we will see you at the next
one Merry Christmas I got a gun in my
pack
you